like I know nobody's gonna work hard for
Tamar like I am right you guys know that
from day one how do you know there's
somebody else is not gonna one thing
aerosol because not just because they'd
like to check because they like the
grind too and you're getting Bob only
show you print you that haven't been
there with it's been a problem
the sound is best up there's something
wrong people are not a place able to be
you have regular show issues like listen
come what I just feel like it's too much
right now I just feel like it's too
close you know we need to kind of take a
step back and just kind of like hit the
reset button and figure things out like
because it's just too much you know for
me you are entitled to do whatever you
want to do you're a grown woman
well at the end of the day whatever you
guys have been doing it's been working
you know it's just really hard trying to
figure out who we are business-wise you
know what I'm saying I'm willing to do
whatever it takes to make your work
[Music]